- Lisa! Hallo! Und Emma!
- Hallo!
- Emma?!
- Lotte!
Tschüss, Lisa.
- Tschüss, meine Süße.
Hab viel Spaß, ja!
- Herzlichen Glückwunsch, Lotte!
Wie alt ist Lotte jetzt?
- Sie ist acht.
- Ah, Emma ist auch acht Jahre alt.
Ich hab hier Emmas Schlafsack
und ihre Isomatte.
- Super, danke!
- Wo hast du deine Traumfrau
kennengelernt?
- Im Fundbüro.
- Im Fundbüro? Hat sie jemand abgegeben?
- Nein, auf gar keinen Fall.
Nein, sie arbeitet da. Ich habe
meine Tasche verloren
und ein Mann hat sie abgegeben.
Dieser Mann war unser Amor.
- Und den Finder der Tasche willst
du suchen?
- Tasche verloren?
- Ganz genau. Er hat mein Leben verändert
und ich würde mich gerne bedanken.
- Also, wenn du das hörst, edler Finder,
dann greif zum Telefon und ruf an.
Die Telefonnummer ist
08007773344.
- 7773344 … 7773344.
Tasche verloren.
- Wir machen kurz Werbung und dann
wollen wir wissen, wen ihr sucht!
Ruft an!